Jonathan Joestar a kind heroic gentle
man of culture someone who is accustomed
to the finer pursuits of life such as
subscribing to the new world review for
regular dirt or content uploaded
straight until YouTube feed and you too
could be a person of culture by doing
just that hello and welcome to the new
order via source for everything anime
manga and most specifically welcome to
Jojo 101 the series that breaks down
everyone and everything within the realm
of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and today we
are going to begin this series by
examining the progenitor of all of this
madness the og Jojo himself Jonathan
Joestar Jonathan Joestar is a tall and
wildly stacked individual who can only
truly be described with one word that
being gentlemen and this man would serve
as the protagonist of part one of JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure being phantom blood
which took place in a classic Victorian
era setting in the realm of England
Jonathan was born in 1868 the son of
George and Mary Joestar although in the
case of the white parent Mary tragically
passed away whilst Jonathan was still a
baby but more on that in a bit because
that accident would actually go on to
define Jonathan's life as well as the
path of his descendants sparking the
entirety of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure as
we know it George Joestar however was a
highly successful merchant businessman
who amassed an incredible array of
wealth so much so that he was able to
purchase an entire estate for his family
to live on with like a mansion and
everything and so Jonathan was
effectively brought up in the realm of
rich English nobility a role in which
Jonathan excelled at even as a child
although with that said he did hold a
more mischievous side but it was all
generally in good fun and his core
aspiration to become a true gentleman
always command at the forefront of his
thoughts other than family two figures
would occupy Jonathan's adolescence the
first of which was his best friend Danny
a particularly cheerful looking Great
Dane although their relationship did not
get off to the greatest of starts as
originally Jonathan acted somewhat
antagonistic towards the pooch causing
him to be fairly timid and fearful
however one day Danny lept into action
in order to save Jonathan from drowning
and from then on the two were
inseparable meanwhile our other figure
of interest would be one Erina Pendleton
a childhood sweetheart of Jonathan one
whom Jonathan willingly took a beating
for actually as one day he intervened to
save Erina from two bullies although
once again that altercation did not work
out too well for Jonathan or did it
because this was the event that would
endear Aaron it
and eventually she went on to become his
girlfriend although rather sadly this is
quite probably where the happy tale of
Jonathan Joestar comes to a bit of an
end unfortunately for the first
protagonist of the series he was also
thrust into some of the most tragic of
circumstances which all came about as a
result of a man named do Brando and this
is where we'll come back to the accident
that killed Mary Joestar on that night
and know the man was presents named
Dario Brando and he discovered the
crashed carriage of the Joestar family
with the intent to loot them however
George Joestar mistook Tara for someone
trying to rescue them and despite the
fact that George would later learn that
Dario was a highly unscrupulous
individual to say the least
he would always retain a sense of debt
in regards to Dario which is why after
Dara's passing George accepted Dario son
do into his household which was the
beginning of Jonathan's living hell
because immediately do seven two of
Jonathan's foundational connections in
this world by murdering Danny because
he's a prick and creating a rift between
Jonathan and Erina at which point Erina
would move to India with her father so
this combined with the fact that George
was a particularly harsh father left
Jonathan in a position of utter
loneliness which would be sustained for
the next eight years of his life always
wary of do but putting on a noble facade
in public
that was until Jonathan discovered that
dear was intentionally poisoning a
rapidly weakening George Joestar in an
attempt to steal the family fortune
after which point Jonathan traveled to
London in search of an antidote which
would lead to a confrontation with a
street thug named Robert yo Speedwagon
and yes I know it's a pretty sounding
name for a thug but there you have it
this was ye olde England after all and
this would constitute another incredibly
important fated meeting in the history
of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure wid
Speedwagon swiftly coming to realise
what kind of man Jonathan was because by
this stage make no mistake Jonathan was
an incredibly powerful and sharp an one
who could have easily killed Speedwagon
and his various minion things
however as Jonathan's top priority in
life had always been the pursuit of
becoming a gentleman this innate
kindness was on full display during this
conflict prompting speedwagon's
overwhelming admiration and for the
first time in eight years Jonathan had
won not only an hour but a trusted
friend a trusted friend who was able to
point Jonathan in the right direction
and find an antidote for his father
after which point Jonathan George and
Speedwagon decided to have do arrested
an act that would not go particularly
well as by this point deer had
discovered
secret behind the stone masks an object
that he used on himself actively casting
away his humanity and becoming what was
essentially some sort of immortal
vampire and of course while this event
ensued Jorge would sacrifice himself to
save Jonathan and so this poor poor man
lost yet another of his most paramount
connections to this world and at this
point Jonathan resolved to put an end to
the monster formerly known as do and I
guess also now currently known as do but
in doing so Jonathan made the decision
to set his mansion on fire in order to
secure an opportunity to defeat the
monster that had plagued his life which
seemingly worked because deer was
impaled although he would go on to
survive as he often does but some
much-needed good news for Jonathan right
now as after the battle he woke up being
nursed by the love of his life Erina
Pendleton the first time he'd seen her
in seven years and the two were given a
long-awaited opportunity to reconnect
however this is where the story of
Jonathan would take a truly bizarre turn
as he was approached by a man named will
Antonio zeppeli who was both the one who
revealed that deer was still alive as
well as the individual who introduced
Jonathan to the art of home on something
that Jonathan would need to master in
order to defeat do once and for all
now zeppeli was it was a stranger man
than Jonathan was used to encountering
in his day-to-day life however despite
that Jonathan developed another fairly
incredible bond here and eventually came
to place complete trust in zeppeli who
acted as both a mentor and a friend the
mental part is what we'll focus on
though because Emily gave Jonathan a
whole host of strange tasks to complete
in his pursuit of home on one of which
included defeating a zombie incarnation
of Jack the Ripper without spilling a
glass of wine but you know in context it
didn't seem that weird but having said
it out loud I guess that is pretty
bizarre
in any case Jonathan and zeppeli would
face many challenges together one of
which would be directly squaring off
against a much more powerful vampire
dear witch and this is a trend by now
yet it didn't go very well for them not
very well at all however by this time
Jonathan was showing some pretty extreme
promise in regards to his training and
he was able to invoke come on to defeat
Bruford a zombified 16th century knight
interestingly enough in the process
proof had regained his human soul and
developed a level of profound respect
for Jonathan even deciding to leave his
sword to a part one protagonist which
led to that ever infamous look and pluck
moment which seems really weird if
you're not familiar with 19th century
English literature which
he wasn't but pluck refers to the idea
of needing to succeed in this world via
hardship or various stories where a
character has their inheritance or
position in society stolen causing them
to work to regain it all of which is
very effectively embodied in Jonathan
Joestar but the tragedy is not quite
over yet not quite door as during a
subsequent battle against another zombie
knight named caucus
zeppeli made the decision to sacrifice
himself in order to save Jonathan and in
doing so zeppeli transferred his home on
into the fleshy vessel that lost
Jonathan providing him with the power
required to defeat Tarkus however it
came at the cost of yet another of his
dear friends but now I come down to the
main event
as Jonathan strived forward in the
pursuit of a final confrontation with
dear a man who had been consistently
ruining not only his life but the lives
of all of those around him and after a
heated and surprisingly calculated
battle Jonathan would prove superior to
do finishing him off with a hormone
infused punch straight into dears
vampire stomach and sent his body flying
off a balcony
lady Lee to rest and never be seen again
but okay we'll get to that after this
confrontation of Jonathan's cohort made
sure to destroy the stone mask so that
it's power could never be accessed again
I mean unless there were save multiple
stone masks in existence but that would
be pretty unlikely now wouldn't it
but now getting down to business roughly
two weeks after dears defeat Jonathan
married Erina which look I don't know
how many of you have ever planned a
wedding but all I'll say to this couple
for accomplishing that in two weeks is
good job guys and to celebrate Jonathan
and Erin are now Erina Joestar went on
to board a ship to America where they
plan to spend their honeymoon and I say
plan because well as per usual do shows
up to ruin everything and given that
he's just ahead this time around dears
plan here was to steal Jonathan's body
and in an attempt to once again endear
once and for all again Jonathan use ha
Mon to set off an explosion within the
ship intended to engulf both he and do
and that explosion did indeed happen
meanwhile Erina was able to escape at
the request of Jonathan carrying an
infant in her arms and a future Joestar
in her womb and sadly that would bring
an end to the tragic yet heroic and
truly gentlemanly life in times of
Jonathan Joestar some more fun facts
about Jonathan Joestar to keep piling on
with dia tragedy Jonathan's final
efforts were not in fact a success as
dia would go on to survive the explosion
and a fix
head to Jonathan's body leading him to
once again becoming the main antagonist
of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure during part
3 being Stardust Crusaders this does
lead to a couple of very intriguing
things regarding Jonathan though the
first of which being that during part
three it was confirmed that Jonathan had
the potential to be a stand user with
his ability being awoken by do now in
control of his body the stand was never
canonically named but it does bear great
resemblance to Herman purple the stand
wielded by Joseph Joestar grandson of
Jonathan however I should say that the
stand is named in other materials one of
which being JoJo's Bizarre Adventure /
heaven which rather creatively called it
her matte purple - and the George
Joestar novel where it was dubbed the
passion speaking of George Joestar
though that would be the name of the son
that Jonathan would never get to meet
however George in a really bizarre twist
would not be Jonathan's only biological
son as due to do impregnating various
women Jonathan technically has a whole
host of biological children out there in
the world the most prominent of which
would be John or Giovanna main
protagonist of part 5 golden wind which
is pretty crazy to think about because
Jonah was born in 1985 which if you are
keeping score is more than a century
after Jonathan was born according to our
key the author of the manga Jonathan was
actually a really difficult character to
design because he was deliberately
attempting to create a symbol of purity
and dignity rather than a fresh and
intriguing character for the manga
reading audience to digest and I saw
Sharky had a lot of trouble writing the
character because he felt quite boxed in
by the very strict attributes that he
had granted Jonathan interestingly
enough our key and his editor had
decided on Jonathan being the name of
the series protagonist before they came
up with the name of the series itself
and from here Archy wanted to take
advantage of alliteration at which point
they landed on the Joestar surname and
then the nickname of Jojo a combination
of Jonathan and Joestar which then
became JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and
finally a truly useless fact Jonathan
Joestar appears in each and every single
chapter of phantom blood which actually
makes him the only Jojo protagonist to
appear in every single chapter of their
respective part and that pretty much
does it for Jonathan Joestar but what do
you guys think please do let me know it
down in the comments below if you came
for some old Jojo content then please do
feel free to check out some of my other
videos I'll even subscribe to the
channel for regular Georgia Wanda to
live it straight until YouTube feed but
for now this has been the new older
you and I'll see you next time